economía en directo américa de frank son
24 ya está lista conmigo en el estudio
daniela blandón danny que es lo más
reciente el pulso por el gas en europa
al aragón muy buenos días viernes
finalmente tiene finalmente descansar y
hablar el lunes recargados mi señor pues
le cuento que las entregas de gas ruso a
europa a través de tres rutas
principales de gasoductos se mantuvieron
prácticamente estables este viernes esto
es lo que reporta la agencia reuters
rusia efectivamente detuvo el suministro
de gas a polonia bulgaria esta semana
recordemos por negarse a pagar en rublos
aunque polonia se dice que todavía sigue
recibiendo lo a través de terceros
países como por ejemplo alemania la
unión europea como bloque se niega
entonces a cumplir las demandas del
kremlin y no descarta inclusive revivir
el debate sobre un posible embargo de
hidrocarburos rusos y es que el kremlin
quiere darle un impulso también con
todas estas medidas al rublo que cerró
la semana en su nivel más alto en más de
dos años frente al euro y también subió
frente al dólar aunque esta semana ha
estado más respaldada por estos
controles de capital que ha impuesto el
gobierno por un nuevo recorte del banco
central de su tasa de interés que pasó
del 17% al 14% todo para fortalecer el
grupo así es danny bueno eso en la
guerra y pasamos ahora a hablar de otro
tema muy interesante muy importante un
tema que a usted le encanta de qué
estamos hablando de daniela ahora
abrimos semana con twitter cerramos
semana con twitter worker y por qué
porque precisamente dani publicó los
resultados financieros qué pasó cómo
está la empresa la del señor y es que
pues mire después de haber anunciado que
llegó a un acuerdo para que y los moscas
se quedara con el 100% de la compañía
twitter primero recordó que todavía
faltan las autorizaciones regulatorias y
que se espera que negocio se cierre en
el transcurso del 2022 no es que hoy él
sea el dueño no el magnate de hecho
anunció la venta de unos 4 mil millones
de dólares en acciones de tesla
posiblemente para concretar esta compra
cuanto antes y es que twitter ahora si
le respondo su pregunta es una firma que
en los últimos años raúl ha subido
ingresos pero no ha logrado consolidar
efectivamente un crecimiento sostenido
en sus ganancias veamos en el primer
trimestre de este año como estuvieron
las cifras
entraron en caja 1.200 millones de
dólares 16% más que en el mismo periodo
del año pasado y también generó
ganancias de más de 500 millones de
dólares pero esto fue gracias a la venta
de su división de publicidad para
aplicaciones móviles
que se llama mou pop por más de mil
millones de dólares y no precisamente
por su operación y en el mercado se dice
que sus resultados no cumplieron con las
expectativas y que si se cierra el
negocio con hilo en moscú sería de muy
buen interés para los accionistas que no
tienen mucho más que esperar
económicamente hable y como no pueda ni
en términos de los nuevos usuarios de
esta plataforma bueno mire que o algo
bien interesante dentro de este informe
y es que el gigante de redes sociales
dijo haber agregado 12 millones de
nuevos usuarios en el primer trimestre y
que ahora tiene 229 millones de usuarios
diarios monetizables ellos son los que
miran los anuncios efectivamente y le
generan ingresos sin embargo la empresa
también hizo una
confesión bien preocupante y es que
reconoció haber exagerado las cifras de
usuarios trimestrales en determinados
reportes del 2019 2020 y 2021 y lo
atribuyó a un error de cálculo interno
sólo los dos últimos años la diferencia
con las cifras reales fue de 15 millones
de usuarios sí pero un error que no fue
de un usuarios en el 11
danny pero tras tanto tecnológicas
también reportaron resultados y qué
empresas estamos hablando claro de
adivina cuál fue el común denominador de
todas en el primer trimestre con
resultados resultados aumentaron la
guerra en ucrania la granja sana también
que obviamente les pasa factura a todos
todos los gremios a todo el mundo claro
con excepción de algunos de cosas que vi
se están viendo beneficiados pero
entonces miremos estas víctimas así
comenzamos por amazon cuyos resultados
fueron catalogados por analistas como
decepcionantes el minorista línea más
grande del mundo si subió sus ventas en
7% pasó son los 100 mil millones de
dólares pero también tuvo unas pérdidas
de 3 mil 800 millones por cuenta de los
costos más altos de entregar los
paquetes en las casas de los usuarios en
el caso de apple estamos hablando del
segundo trimestre fiscal
en enero y marzo sus ingresos subieron
pero además de la guerra las cuarentenas
en china por kobe 19 afectaron su
operación es que casi todas las fábricas
chinas que realizan este ensamblaje
final de productos redujeron su
operación y todavía persiste también la
escasez de semiconductores para el
próximo trimestre la empresa cree que el
golpe sería de entre 4 mil y 8 mil
millones de dólares por toda esta
operación y terminamos con facebook que
no decepcionó tanto sus ingresos del
primer trimestre aumentaron 7% cerró con
casi 2 mil millones de usuarios activos
diarios danny y como usted sabe todo y
puede ver el futuro a lo mejor que
podemos seguir viendo la semana que
viene en términos económicos por
supuesto twitter no da ni pero a lo
mejor que más podemos ver si no pues
estaremos muy pendientes sobre todo de
twitter vamos a tenerles un informe muy
chévere sobre inflación en turquía y
bueno esperar a ver como más nos va a
afectar esta sequía también en india con
las cosechas de sigo tenemos un montón
de noticias el trigo -afectado además
dan y porque lo vemos
en la guerra en ucrania en rusia y
ucrania porque son los casi que los
mayores graneros del mundo y después
ahorita lo estamos viendo con esta
sequía en asia también el trigo
-afectado para porque envía y va a ser
el que lleva a reemplazar esos esos
pedidos de trigo de ucrania y de rusia y
ahora con la sequía no puede hacerlo
entonces veremos precios más altos del
trigo del pan que le gusta y de muchos
pasitos con un café danny
bueno muchísimas gracias entonces como
siempre por toda la información
económica nos vemos el lunes con más